When Donald Trump won the presidential electionin 2016,
even though 2.8 million more people voted for Hillary Clinton,
everyone on the left from Bill de Blasio to Michael Moore to Eric Holder to Bill Maher
said that at long last, "we have to just abolish the Electoral College."
Then California Senator Barbara Boxer introduceda bill
to amend the U.S. Constitution to do just that.
A Gallup poll from September of this year
showed that 61 percent of Americans support abolishing the Electoral College
in favor ofa national popular vote.
Although it's an issue that breaks along partisan lines
with 77 percent of Republicans wanting to keep the Electoral College
and 89 percent of Democrats saying weshould get rid of it.
Is the Electoral College the best system for electing a president?
That was the subject of an online Soho Forum debate
held on Wednesday, November 11, 2020.
RichardEpstein, a law professor at New York University,
defended the system against Lawrence Lessig, a law professor at Harvard.
Here's Richard Epstein and Lawrence Lessig
in an online debate moderated by Soho Forum Director Gene Epstein.